hashem abedi wasn't there to see the
judge deliver him
a life sentence for two days he's
refused to enter the courtroom
but amongst those that were there to
hear his sentence with the families of
his 22 victims
watching either in person in court in
london or via live video links from
locations across the country
i'm feeling a bit numb about it because
to be quite honest it's never going to
bring olivia back
steve and sharon goodman watched from
manchester uh
their 15 year old granddaughter olivia
was one of the several
children killed in the attack i find it
very disrespectful that he couldn't
come into court he wouldn't face up his
actions that's the disrespect
yeah i think it's contemptible i think
it was arrogant
i think it's bravado i think it's
typical of a young person
i can't understand it i can't comprehend
it
it was hashem abadi's older brother
salman who detonated the suicide bomb at
the end of an ariana grande concert at
manchester arena
in may 2017 but a court ruled that
hashem was just as guilty
key in planning and buying materials to
make the bomb that killed and maimed
so many amongst his victims was 29 year
old martin hett
he was days away from moving to america
but decided to go to one last gig
as a mum i can't reconcile and i don't
think i ever will do
and i don't think any amount of therapy
will help me that
i can't reconcile in my head that my son
lay
down on a stone floor dead for about 10
minutes before i even knew about it
and i was spending that time asleep it
just doesn't
feel okay as a mom i should have been
there for him and
that guilt will stay with me probably
for the rest of my days
hashem and salman obedy were born and
grew up here
in manchester although their parents
were from libya
their mother and father returned there
in 2016 but the brothers decided to stay
here hashem and salmon went to visit
their parents in april
2017 but only salman would come back to
carry out the attack
whilst hashem stayed behind in libya
would you give me your full name a date
of birth please
my name is hashim abedi the prime
minister today thanked the services that
helped bring hashem abadi back to face
justice it's taken three years to get to
this point
he's clearly a very callous and
calculating individual i think you know
his
his behavior through the trial shows
this the fact that when he was there
when he was present
they had little regard for for what was
going on in the proceedings
the good thing is he's going to have a
very long time in a very small prison
cell to reflect on his behavior
hashem abedi will be in his late 70s
before he's allowed out of prison
but his actions have left hundreds with
life-changing mental
and physical injuries and families
living with a loss from which they say
they will never recover catherine of a
toxic sky news
in manchester